[Music]
[Music]
little top a quiet hurricane community
[Music]
after a busy day at the office the shop
or perhaps one of the local plans
[Music]
but some plants like this newspaper
operate 24 hours a day yes news is
always in the making
mad dog bite 18 here
here's a special announcement the County
Health Department has declared an
epidemic of rabies in Butler County
89 cases of rabies and dogs have
occurred in the county during the past
three months and 165 persons have
received vaccine treatment today 18
people were bitten by one rabid dog
roaming through Middletown this dog is
you to watch the wounds with soap and
warm running water then consult your
physician or the County Health
Department to determine whether vaccine
treatment will be required the County
Health Department is called in dr.
Joseph Fisher the state public health
veterinarian and dr. Burton Richards the
rabies control expert from the United
States Public Health Service to set up
emergency control measures if you are
the owner of a dog who's been bitten
take your pet to the nearest Animal
Clinic or humane shelter for vaccination
authorities say that once rabies
develops in man or animal it is a
hundred percent fatal get in touch with
your physician or veterinarian as soon
as possible be sure to keep your pets
indoors until the County Health
Department declares that this epidemic
is under control for further news stay
tuned to this station
[Music]
this dying animal paralyzed and helpless
has caused fear anxiety and costly
damage in Middletown picked up by the
dog warden the dog is taken to the local
humane shelter for observation the dog
died and its head was sent to the health
department here in a small isolated room
the brain is removed from the skull for
examination for positive evidence of
rabies it is safe to delay human vaccine
treatment provided that laboratory
facilities are immediately available
diagnosis is determined by the finding
of negra bodies within any portion of
the brain containing nerve cells but
negra bodies are most prevalent in the
Amin's horn this aughh had rabies dr.
Brown was notified immediately and
injections began 14 painful injections
one every day the strain took its toll
of the parents as well as the child
Tommy would get well 18 people in
Middletown would get well but they would
always remember that once rabies
develops it's 100% fatal in the meantime
the emergency program the control the
epidemic was in full swing
[Music]
don't you mind that way
[Music]
okay you will lie against me and you're
gone vaccinated today
[Music]
and will evolve back when he will again
reading today through the cooperation of
the entire community
80% of all dogs were immunized in one
week the emergency control program
showed excellent results although these
were emergency animal clinics they were
set up with authorized procedures for
inoculating all dogs in any community in
any state standard vaccination
certificates were issued by the County
Health Department owners were advised to
inoculate their dogs at least once a
year to keep their dogs on leashes or
confined at home for 30 days until the
vaccine was fully effective all dogs
were inoculated with a vaccine approved
by the US Bureau of animal industry
[Music]
with ladies under control the people of
Middletown were determined to keep it
out of the community for good the state
Public Health veterinarian call a
meeting of all private practicing
veterinarians physicians public health
officers and leading citizens to set up
a prominent long range control program
in every community in the state and for
that reason we have asked dr. Richards
to explain how the United States Public
Health Service is coping with this
problem we know how to control rabies
other countries have done so we can do
the same our foreign quarantine measures
require the inoculation of all dogs
entering the United States yet millions
of our own dogs are unprotected stray
dogs must be reported to the local
health departments and properly
impounded inhumane shelter ladies in
wild animals is also an important
problem in many parts of the country our
US Fish and Wildlife Service is helping
the states carry out trapping programs
during epidemics of ravings every year
millions of dollars are lost the dairy
farmers and cattle breeding thousands of
injections are given to people bitten by
rabbit doll parents and children
suffering fear this need not be we must
recognize the seriousness of Raving we
must assume a personal responsibility
ever owned dogs inoculated and then get
the rest of the community to do the same
in the states and the states themselves
must join the National rabies control
program we can win the fight against
rabies
[Music]
you